these 3d printed speakers were designed
and printed using digital material
technologies on an object right so
basically you put in two different
cartridges material and it can mix um
various ways so you can get a whole
spectrum from really really flexible
it's really rigid different optical
properties we looked at this and we said
we have a clear material here let's see
what happens when we put a light in it
so we took this flashlight right here
and put that in there and wow wow it's
really cool so then we were having lunch
with our buddies at luma geek and they
said we showed this to them and they
said let's light this up let's do this
alright so I brought down some of the
luma geek development kit and what we do
at lungi is we have this sort of
development toolkit and go directly from
our cell phone into this little mobile
rig and next thing you know we decided
to start coiling up some strip and
stuffing it inside and you can see that
you just you don't get a one-for-one
sort of mapping to the addressable
pixels but you get something that's much
more artistic and beautiful and there's
a little bit of diffusion and color
blending so this is a new kind of LED
strip yes this is a high-density
addressable LED strip that actually if
you look really closely on the strip
you'll see that every LED has a very
very tiny microprocessor in it and it
wouldn't have to be just in a speaker
you could you could stick this all kinds
of places where it would respond to
ambient noise or directly from via and
audio in absolutely so you can do a line
in you can throw this in your car you
can throw this in your bike out at
Burning Man you could wrap yourself up
in this for Halloween so these are not
just really pretty speakers they're 3d
printed they've gotten addressable LED
strip in there but you can't get them so
that's why luma geek has this shield it
lets you easily control an LED strip of
your own so you can use it in any kind
of project and make your own
you